la empresa viva era anunció en un
comunicado que suspendía toda venta de
tiquetes de manera inmediata y también
que dejaba en tierra a toda su flota
debido a estas dificultades financieras
por las que viene atravesando está
dejando entonces varados en los
aeropuertos a cientos de pasajeros que
tenían tiquetes en vuelos nacionales e
internacionales y quienes han venido
protagonizando protestas y bloqueos ya
las autoridades aeronáuticas acaban de
anunciar que para usuarios con reservas
confirmadas Entre hoy y mañana las otras
aerolíneas latam Avianca y satena están
ofreciendo rutas compartidas sin ningún
costo adicional dependiendo del cupo
libre que tengan Bueno pero qué fue lo
que los llevó a esta situación pues mire
Esa es la empresa de bajo costo más
concurrida en el país en la pandemia
entró en quiebra porque tuvo que dejar
sus aviones en tierra ya en 2022 le
afectaron en alto costo del combustible
y la devaluación del peso colombiano
Avianca que es la aeronimia más antigua
del continente y la más grande de
Colombia quiere comprarla pero viva Air
dice que la aeron civil que es el
regulador aéreo Lleva más de 7 meses
analizando esa integración por
cuestiones de competencia y no ha dado
ninguna respuesta por el contrario
decidió agregar al proceso a otros cinco
interesados que son aerolíneas
argentinas jetsmart o el mismo gigante
regional latam Airlines que aseguran que
se verían afectados con esta decisión e
incluso han mostrado interés en
comprarla entonces según viva Colombia
lo que está haciendo la autoridad es
dilatando el proceso bueno Y
concretamente entonces qué es lo que
está diciendo la entidad al respecto
bueno la empresa dice que esta decisión
sin precedentes por parte de la entidad
va a dar como resultado nuevos retrasos
en la toma de una decisión por lo que
viva se vio obligada a anunciar la
suspensión de sus operaciones con efecto
inmediato y la aeronáutica civil le
responde que si se fusiona con Avianca
vivaa tendría el 100% de participación
en 16 rutas nacionales y que en términos
de libre competencia Esto va a
significar un retroceso
volver a niveles que no se veían en el
país hace más de siete años en términos
de de competencia la empresa en últimas
dice que va a seguir en un proceso de
reorganización de sus deudas mientras
espera una decisión final de la
aeronáutica civil